lanny davis is a communications advisor
to michael cohen he was previously one
of Cohen's attorneys Davis is here for
his first morning Network television
ever since Cohen's sentencing good
morning Linda the prosecutors in this
case said that Cohen elected not to
pursue more fulsome cooperation what
else does he know about President Trump
that he is not telling I don't know the
lawyer for mr. Cohen never shared that
information with me and neither did
Michael and I know that he wanted to
come in and talk to the prosecutors in
the Southern District and they waited
until the Friday before the guilty plea
on Monday and I don't know why they
waited but I do know that he fully
cooperated with mr. Muller who
complimented him and gave him full
credit for that
well Lanny part of his sentence is two
months for lying to Congress which we
heard from the Muller team right when
you were here in August 22nd earlier
this year you were asked if he was
telling the truth when he spoke in
testified before Congress you said yes
so was your client not being forthright
with you or were you not being
forthright with us I think the testimony
that I was referring to was on another
subject than the one about the Trump
Tower which I knew nothing about never
heard about but the answer is yes I
believe that he had been truthful in his
testimony before Congress is that what
he told you
yes there's still a lot of eye rolls I
think for Michael Cohen yesterday you
know he talked about his love of country
his love of his family I think some
people say where was his love of country
and his love of family that he only
agreed to cooperate when his own when
when he was when he was in trouble in
his ways and say his butt is on the line
what do you say to that well first I'd
asked everybody to please read his
statement yesterday I was even struck by
his ownership and his lack of taking a
victim but full personal responsibility
and it's a very moving statement if you
read it the other thing I would say is
in 1974 John Dean had
committed obstruction of justice paid
hush money did a lot of very very evil
and highly criminal activity and yet we
did finally give him a new life when he
spoke the truth to the Congress and that
may happen to Michael Cohen it may not
be I feel about mr. Trump now very very
scared for the country and for his
family which is his primary reason for
calling me and he had to convince me
over several hours of conversation that
he deeply had changed and had been
transformed as the word he used but it
was because of a fear of Donald Trump
and the country and his family as he
said to mr. Stephanopoulos in his first
interview Michael Cohen is going to jail
in part because of these arrangements to
the women that that Trump allegedly had
an affair with he has also provided
according to the special counsel robert
muller usefull information concerning
discrete russia related matters core to
the investigation that he obtained by
virtue of his regular contact with
company executives at the Trump
Organization what else does your client
know about contacts and coordination
between the Russian government and the
Trump campaign so I really don't know
the specifics but I know that when mr.
Muller uses the expression core yeah mr.
Muller gave great credit to the
cooperation for 70 hours and seven
meetings there was a stutter step in the
first meeting which was corrected that
mr. Muller noted but the core word is
about the heart of mr. Mullens
assignment on collusion so I don't know
where to tell mr. Muller I don't know
beyond the seventy hours but I suspect
that there is always more detail that
can be filled in by mr. Muller and Lana
you know it does come down to
credibility and you know what the
president and his supporters are saying
he they're saying that that mr. Cohen is
a liar
and that he's weak and not to be trusted
why should the American public trust
Michael Cohen well first of all to have
President Trump used the word lie when
he was on Air Force One that denied me
any payments only to have rudy guiliani
immediately say oh yes he did is
somewhat obvious to people that that's
not a strong defense by mr. Trump I
think that Michael has to a challenge to
convince people that he's credible and
now there's corroborating testimony with
the ami and finally I would remind
everyone that it's about facts it's not
about believing someone and those facts
have to be corroborated all right many
thank you thank you very much thank you
for being joining us today